everyone's in lockdown you're not even  allowed to go to elementary school  parents reach out and they're like our  kid is so  alone at home what do people do right  now if they're missing out on those  developmental two to four  years oh they can play with them it's  very very important for children to play  if your children don't have other  children to play with then you play with  them they need to play children are very  resilient i wouldn't jump to the  conclusion that they're going to be  permanently damaged by this period of  relative deprivation  especially if they have parents who care  for them and who are doing what they can